I look at recruitment in a different way
I just build relationships so in my
business we focus a lot on outbound
messaging outbound emailing regulative
candidates whereas I wanted to look at
this job differently and think if I can
genuinely build friendships within this
Market that's gonna serve me well good
things happen to good people right I now
have coffee dates with clients I have
clients that set me up with their
friends that have you know tips about
diabetes or tips about mental health
just focusing on relationships rather
than outcomes and fees has been
imperative and you've got to do that
from day one building a brand as well
has been instrumental for me on LinkedIn
for inbound leads and that's something
that I've been passionate about since
day one posting three times a week
without fail Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
8 A.M I'm there I'm visible and they
come to me and they suggest me because
I'm everywhere on LinkedIn